had lots of input as to the aversive
techniques that were used
for conversion therapy
to be honest with you there is no
federal
or state accreditation program for
someone to become a conversion therapist
so
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome led live family we have a little
bit different of a look today but we are
excited to bring you yet another
controversial topic
what about conversion yeah what is that
i mean what is conversion we talk a lot
on this show about a converted heart we
truly believe that god is the ultimate
one that is
a life changer and when
we're going to talk about converters
like on a car like is this a mechanic
thing that's right that's right we're
going to talk about something
controversial like your conversion
on your car
no
because i'm not qualified
yes
well i don't think i'm i'm qualified
most of the time to talk about much of
the stuff on here but uh you know who is
qualified god is qualified and i'm
excited to dive into this topic because
i think there's a lot of confusion being
thrown around today
um so what about conversion what what
what do you mean by converting people
well you know i guess historically
i'm not in the business of conversion i
mean i can't really do that myself
and but i know that if we invite the
holy spirit which is what i had to do
when i gave my life back to christ
you know i lived in lgbt culture for 40
years
and i came to a point on my own i mean
the church didn't come and get me you
know
nobody i mean they were praying for me
and um
i think there's a lot to be said about
the power of prayer
and i would say those prayers came and
got me and my parents had been praying
for a long time
and i sat down and i had that
conversation with with god and i said
you know what do you want from me and
god pointed back to me and said that
what he wanted from me was intimacy
and i realized then that i thought oh i
have the antidote for this whole gay
thing was that god was courting me
and so he wanted me to respond by
courting him
so how could i really arrive at any
conclusions unless i was actually
engaging in what he gave
me to help guide my life
so
um for you that have not heard wayne's
testimony and you want to hear that
first i highly suggest click on the link
in the description below because we'll
put a link to his testimony powerful
powerful testimony on how god really got
a hold of your heart reached your heart
even brought you into ministry work
today
and and is set your feet on the path
that you are doing today
um it truly is a remarkable story i i've
heard it before been blessed i've known
wayne for quite a few years now um in
fact first met you
10 12 years ago maybe when when you were
starting your ministry was when we were
starting our ministry and so it was we
we worked together for a while and then
you know we've we've gone
individually different directions but on
the same course that's right yeah and
it's neat to see how god's worked
through your work and through your
ministry and what he's done in your life
over the course of these years and
you know god is constantly working on us
and that's i think the meat of today's
topic really is
what is god really doing like what is he
really wanting from us what do you
really mean by conversion right you know
i think the mere mention of christianity
and lgbt
it it already it already
inflames people some people see it as
political some people see it as
controversial but um
yeah it does it does raise a
conversation that i think is worth
having especially from a christian
perspective about what we do what we
don't do that's right what the goal is
and what it's not yeah so let's dive
into it what is the goal yeah so from a
christian perspective and i you know
recently i've been saying in my
presentations
and and i want to address more
specifically today
um certainly include all listeners but
but specifically an lgbt listener
who
whose thoughts still have to do about
god and what what does god desire of me
because lgbt activism and lgbt culture
did not it does not have jesus roots
it it its roots are from the sexual
revolution of which i grew up in in in
stonewall which was the bar where these
rights began
in new york city
they didn't come together to worship
jesus in that bar they came together to
make a sexual contact or the drag queens
were coming in and there were all kinds
of things about a liberal libertarian
type of movement
that was combating against um law the
government at that time and in the riot
essentially that took place there
it um that that is all well and fine for
people who are not deciding for christ
but if you're thinking of christ in the
fact that
you
sense that you're lgbt so i would like
to make a clarification that your
desires and temptations don't equal your
identity
but the lgbt community and even some
church members would say oh if you look
effeminate or you sound more feminine
than male then you know you must be
trans or you must be gay or you must be
all these things but the word of god
doesn't tell me that i'm heterosexual it
doesn't tell me that i'm gay it doesn't
tell me i'm bi and so what i have to
firm
to firmly put my hope in is in the word
of god of what it says and what it
doesn't say and so conversion to me
is about
letting go of self
and deciding that i want to be who
christ says i am
and so in second corinthians 5 17 tells
me that when i give my life over to
christ i become a new creation in him
and it goes on to say in verse 18 and 19
that we should involve ourselves in the
reconciliation
of the message that christ has for us
and so that's why i see this topic today
is one
for the hopeful listener
wanting to find out their value and
their purpose and their identity in
jesus christ amen
i i believe that
the homosexual topic is
not just a
sort of sub-category of okay these are
people that deal with this over here and
the majority of society does not deal
with this um i think this is a topic
that really actually touches almost
everybody
um it deals with freedom
do you have the freedom to love who you
want to and to be who you want to yes
you do yeah you you actually god allows
us that freedom does is that maybe what
god designs for us well that's what
we're going to try to define and discuss
today um um but you do god allows you
that freedom to to live out that life
and i think the bible gives us
principles that says if you order your
life like this
there are some consequences to maybe
maybe doing that right right um and and
that's with everything yes yes if i if
i'm a straight male and i and i decide
that you know i don't really want to
uphold my marriage and and i want to go
out and be with as many females as
possible there's consequences to the
legal consequences and legal
consequences
the bible yeah the bible talks about
those consequences so um
this is not just a matter of are you
able to do this this really kind of
stems back to what is actually the
design that god um has designed for us
and and that may be different than the
way the world sees it you know what i
mean like the world
might not be viewing it through that
lens
so what narrative are you listening to
that's that's probably at the core of
this is that there is a narrative that
comes from god which is one that asks
for us to trust abide and follow him
surrender and live according to his will
not my own
and then there are many other narratives
out there today now the one that
particularly has the spotlight at the
moment and is gaining the spotlight more
and more and has since the 70s is the
lgbt plus spotlight and as you know more
letters get added every single day
but it's beginning to cause a store a
store as it relates to this element of
conversion in fact let's look at a
little piece of of
what that's about i think you have a
clip that really stirred and perked my
interest and saw i thought maybe we
should all have a conversation about
this let's do it so introduce this clip
what are we going to see so this is um
for those of you that don't know um
conversion therapy
is outlawed in 14 countries around the
world uh 20 states of the within the
united states and 100 municipalities
but what is conversion therapy
and so as i begin to do well i can tell
you that when i gave my life over to
jesus christ um i began to see
conversion therapy in
amongst my brothers and sisters that
were gay as being something very harmful
and hurtful and it was like that's
jesus isn't that way and so this
ministry is not going to be that way and
so i've been defending for the last 12
years that i am very much against you
know conversion and reparative therapy
from my understanding of what it was and
then as as this all began to surface
more and more each and every day you see
it in the news and um there was a uh an
attorney out of victoria australia
who is bringing this up for um
contemplation and and he had a few
things that i thought were worthy of
contemplating
interesting i'm gonna get i'm gonna look
forward to getting into this because
conversion therapy
is sold as this like sort of ugly nasty
forceful
archaic ability thing yeah that that is
actually cruel to be valuing right so
let me let me let me uh dive into the
conversion therapy laws are proposed for
the state of tasmania g'day i'm mark
niles and this is the truth of it and it
is indeed tasmania's turn for this
controversial conversion and therapy
issue with the tasmanian law reform
institute releasing a report uh that
recommends a whole host of legal changes
in the state premier who is jeremy
rockliff recently appointed has said
that he is going to advance this issue
oh dear the devil is indeed in the
detail but before i get into the weeds
on what is proposed let me get something
straight well first of all i said
tasmania don't tune out if you're not
tasmania because in case you haven't
realized this thing is advancing around
the country it's been to victoria it's
been to the australian capital territory
it's running into tasmania it seems to
be getting worse as it goes not better
so it's relevant to people in all states
where similar projects are on foot and
that would especially include new south
wales western australia but let me get
something else straight before i even
get into this issue of conversion
therapy i just want to point out
something the phrase conversion therapy
is a nonsense okay it's made up by
people who have no understanding of the
concepts at play conversion to be
straight is an act conversion to be
straight what a terrible choice of words
in light of the topic conversion to be
clear is an act of god it is a spiritual
transformation
therapy is an act of man it is a
treatment applied from one person
towards another person okay
god does not
require acts of people to convert
somebody all right uh god does that it's
his work the phrase does not marry
together okay it's linking two concepts
that are not intrinsically connected i
raised that up front because this
confusion and this obfuscation
or maybe it's a bit of both runs right
through the entire way that this issue
is dealt with and you find yourself in
this weird position where you're reading
a report that's talking all about on the
one hand really insane stuff like
coercion and violence and aversion
therapies and all this kind of stuff
it's sick it's kooky and everyone
scratches their head and they wonder
where on earth this is even happening in
a state like tasmania it sounds like
something from the dark ages and indeed
we're going to find out there's precious
little evidence of any of that
but then in the very next breath in the
same report in the same sentence at
times you have things like the simple
belief the gender identity and sexual
orientation ought to conform to a
particular archetype i.e a christian
view
and these things are treated as if
they're all the same
as if they're found together as if the
person who believes the archetype is
somehow implicated in the physical abuse
of gay people um
it's just actually beyond outrageous
in fact it is a giant dog whistle
against people and institutions of
religious faith which are consistently
singled out to implicate them in a
mindset and in behaviors which are
foreign to them which they simply do not
share and which are a million miles away
from anything they have ever conceived
of or thought of
he's bringing up some very interesting
points here because
on one hand i think conversion therapy
is like this sort of
taboo-ish way of of trying to convert
somebody
and he's
he's basically saying like this is this
is something that maybe perhaps at some
point in time this this transpired this
one on but but we don't see that today
right
what does he mean by that well you know
i had lots of input as to the aversive
techniques that were used
for conversion therapy
to be honest with you there is no
federal
or state accreditation program for
someone to become a conversion therapist
so
so if there's no regulation on it then
what is it by definition if you go to
webster's dictionary it will tell you
that it's anything that suggests
somebody
live differently than how they feel
well if we're going to criminalize
that concept
then we could extend way beyond lgbt and
other right areas of life based on
feelings alone right which is exactly
where i'm kind of starting to to wonder
where this is actually going to go
because
yeah that that
you know if the devil starts over here
and you know some extremists probably
you know maybe
mistreated people and and did something
like that you could see how uh people
would naturally have a crazy adversion
to absolutely but then all of a sudden
that throws the baby out with the
bathwater if it's like hey you know this
person is really trying to make a
difference here in this person's life
and you know maybe has some some some
positive ways of helping that person
right so generally when a person goes
for therapy
they you go as a client and you pay for
services you you examine maybe what it
is before you go and you find that the
person is reputable and you want to go
sit down and have therapy
now let's say that you go as somebody
who's overweight
um and you go to weight watchers and
with the intention of losing 100 pounds
and that's what your goal is but when
you come out on the other side maybe you
only lost two
and so do you criminalize weight
watchers
right
we don't or the same with somebody who
goes to aaa expecting to get sober but
they don't because they have a choice
and and god has given us a power of
choice we can choose for him or we can
choose for ourselves
and
so i you know i was talking to somebody
reputable on this topic a psychologist
and says you know you
you may go to get therapy and you may
have certain goals but because the
therapist maybe didn't meet those goals
for you you come out on the other side
and you go oh well well maybe i should
see a different therapist or or try try
a different method towards
whatever helps me meet my goal right but
you don't like take that therapist to
court because you didn't success and you
you can check out at any time right
these these are people that are seeking
willingly seeking
services right so
so i'm beginning to have difficulty
understanding
the um
the narrative
that says
that talks about all these aversive
things that are happening to people i
don't really know
of adverse
aversive style techniques
that are taking place today i think you
have a graphic on
the
states the united states that shows
so we have 20
states within the united states where
conversion therapy is criminal for
someone of the age of 17 and younger
um like in criminal and and conversion
therapy they are defining as anything
that's trying to change that person's
mind absolutely away from that original
intention right so now you know part of
the 14 countries most of the 14th
country recently was canada in january
of this year conversion therapy is
outlawed in canada but the definition of
conversion therapy
runs from the gamut of something that
might be aversive which i don't believe
is actually taking place at least that i
can find
to as minimal as somebody
praying with somebody oh prayer is
considered a
a conversion therapy and it's criminal
in all these 14 countries and you could
go to jail in canada for up to five
years
in victoria australia for 10 years in
norway for 10 years
and
what they don't have are
benchmark cases yet
because you know it's only going to take
an activist that will want to run the
gamut with this
to set the benchmark or the case study
but currently the case studies in the
united states if you go to look at these
um green states here and you want to go
to the case studies and you go look into
the history to find out where they point
they all point before 1980
and before 1980 is when yes maybe shock
therapy and these adverse techniques
were being used but you know they
weren't actually being used by pastors
or by christian therapists right
maybe one or two people might have been
using it over here but you can't all of
a sudden then say well then no therapy
is useful so let's just ban therapy
together and this these were done by by
secular therapists yeah wow
so it i find it particularly interesting
um
that we don't have clear definition but
that but the definition is coming out by
those who have an agenda
who want to and i understand the the
desire to feel the need to be accepted
and appreciated and loved and i'll be
the first person to say
that the church at large has failed
because it's obscure it's different it's
alien to somebody who's heterosexual and
they're like ah yeah you know how do i
treat this bird i don't know and so the
my ministry exists today to help bring
education tell people understand how you
compassionately love and still hold on
to your biblical principles
because
you know from genesis to revelation the
only example we have
is that of marriage between a man and a
woman and there is no intimate
relationship between two same-gendered
individuals no one to this date in 12
years have been able to provide me a
bible text that shows me that god
condones a sexual relationship between
two same-gendered individuals yeah
usually it's not in a positive light
it's it's in a not-so-positive light
right so now today they've switched the
term from queer theology to queer theory
who wants to take those verses and say
well what god really had a problem with
was uh pedophilia
and incest and so redefining kind of
even what that
not only was not from a biblical
direction but from a cultural direction
we're reshaping what the bible means and
what it doesn't mean based on what i
want it to mean
and so god wouldn't um
yeah well god wouldn't condem condone a
same-sex relationship that was love
based in love okay so
is it possible that we've redefined love
to fit the culture rather than honor the
author of love who says what love really
is right and and this is how i want you
guys to experience love and right this
is going to give you the best picture of
my love yeah
so for me i have to look at the at the
when i came to christ i had to look at
we don't talk about satan very much we
have to look at the great controversy
and the great controversy is that
jesus had a plan for all of us
now the plan got kind of messed up in
the sense that we have the stain of sin
on us
and so as i look at the stain of sin i
need to look at the author of sin
to see how did it get so messed up
and so i see that that satan wants to
take
a third of heaven
out
and says that they should follow the
dictates of their own will because
they're holy beings and gives them this
big fluff about how they can decide
independently from god
and
as he goes about doing that
the
the most effective way
to make you believe something other than
the truth which we know is from god
you know you take a 20 bill that's
counterfeit and you and i probably could
sit here and go i don't see anything
counterfeit about it
and so satan does that the same thing
with marriage with gender
with family
with the sabbath you know he's done
these kinds of things and
we seem to be willingly participating
because it appeals to our senses
and
so it to me i i like to
share with people how my footing got off
i understand now how my footing got off
and to somebody who is considering
christ who is identifying as lgbt
i invite you to explore the identity
that christ has for you
yeah it may include celibacy
um and today we see that as a death
sentence
and a lot of people look at me and go
well you're an old man and so you can't
relate well you know i always say when
you're my age write me a letter but then
i won't be i won't be alive then
probably
but
sensuality doesn't disappear but i want
to have my sensuality brought back into
the confines of which god intended for
me to to have that
and god is also in the business of
miracles so somebody who is coming back
to christ
as they deal with the trauma and where
the various different things that took
place in their life
perhaps god may bring them to a level in
their life that they may end up having
appreciation for one person of the
opposite sex because god didn't tell me
that i need to fall in love with the
entire female population or i'd be in
another mess right
yeah
but the idea that that
you are now being prevented or limited
to that converting back into the image
of god and and and maybe when you're
falling in love with god and god's
really working on your heart and saying
hey maybe this isn't the best um um
choice of life for you you should you
know consider this
to basically make that like you cannot
do that
yeah that's crazy it is i mean that so
so i guess primarily what i see that is
dealing with is my human rights
because you know this is what lgbt
activism has been begging for for
decades and you you have arrived at
obtaining your rights
and the scream is for tolerance and for
affirmation
and
what's puzzling to me is that as you've
gained that instead of respecting other
people's
right to have differences of opinion
you're condemning their rights
and their um their ideas of being maybe
different than
than yours are and what gets messed up
in the confusion there is the definition
of love
because you know let's say you commit
adultery
it's not gonna it's not gonna stop me
from continuing to love you i'm gonna be
disappointed that why why did he go down
that road when he had a perfectly
wonderful lady in his life his wife and
my heart is broken for you
but
but you you know if you turned around
and said you know well i want to
criminalize you for disapproving of my
my uh divorce or whatever the case may
be i'm like what yeah i love you dude i
care about you so why are you doing that
to me
it's it's retaliatory and it's ugly and
it doesn't make the lgbt community look
inviting and caring and loving in of
itself right wow i mean this is this is
crazy to even think that in our day and
age we're even having these
conversations right now but i can see
such a greater implication of this um
sure it's going to start off with this
topic here but where does it stop i mean
if if if i'm actually seriously being
prevented from being able to pray for
somebody
i mean that could have such far-reaching
implications of of everything i mean
that what what would keep you where
you're at right you know if it's all of
a sudden criminalized for you to even
you know tell somebody that hey
you know i i'm viewing this through the
biblical lens and and this is my world
view and and i believe there's a
difference between right and wrong and
here's what i believe it is based on
what i believe god is telling us to live
like right and and now it's like that's
starting to get eroded away yes so so if
cases are brought before me where i see
that somebody is really actually getting
shock therapy against their will and
then and and aversive techniques that
are destroying them as a human being i
am the first person to sign that's right
on the dotted line that is not okay that
has got to go yeah you know but for
let's say that you know i'm hearing now
about like a a camp that was focused on
conversion therapy okay so if a group of
men come together and they want to
discuss about what would be better in
their lives as as
as god facilitating
relationships between men that doesn't
include sexual intimacy
sure if that's if that's what you guys
want to do that's your right to be able
to do that it's not harming or hurting
anybody else around you
and so to criminalize that
it's it's starting to sound like a
marxist movement it is to say that we
all have to be carbon copies of the
other person yeah well i i truly believe
in freedom uh freedom to believe how you
want i mean god allows us that freedom
right
he did not control satan
when lucifer was in heaven and he said
you know what i don't want to live by
your rules god did not say
that you know i'm gonna all of a sudden
make you i'm gonna tie your hands i'm
gonna make you right
he pleaded with him tried to work with
him and then of course it was causing
discord in heaven so he could not be
living there doing the same sort of
thing so god had to remove him from that
situation or destroy him and an unfair
god would have destroyed him right right
but he allowed him that choice to be
able to play out and i think that
because god allows us that freedom we
can choose whatever we want in this
country
we started a country that really was was
based out of
us getting controlled right in a
religious sense yeah and and all of a
sudden it was like no we believe that
everyone should have the right to
believe and and and the power of choice
the power of choice and now we're
starting to see that actually get
flipped on its head yeah and it's like
no you can you can you can you can do
whatever you want you just can't believe
like this and in fact we'll we'll make
sure that you don't believe like this
so
you
you can see how
society is being manipulated and from a
governmental standpoint if you can get
the year of a politician and make a
campaign for that then those who
disagree are not they're they're muffled
by the loud voices who are screaming and
hollering and the cases that are paid
attention to
are campaigned for with all kinds of
techniques to make a legislator believe
what you're bringing i know i i have um
friends in other ministries today who
are putting before
courts today and saying hold on wait a
minute let's say a 19 a nine-year-old
girl
gets sexually molested by her father
and you know here she is 11 12 years old
now she's thinking well i'm really uh
i'm really a boy and not a girl i mean
if we begin to look at the psychology of
this we can i i'm not even a
psychologist and i can begin to tell you
that ah i can see how she's gonna start
thinking i should be a boy not a girl
or there are other incidences when i
didn't fit into society and in my youth
um i was teased bullied and harassed
because i was effeminate and and i
didn't do well in sports and i i stood
before the mirror i was begging god
please you know you made a mistake and i
should have been a girl and not a boy
but what he didn't really
um evaluate
was what the effect of sin that had on
this world why i was in the
circumstances that i was in and how god
if i had kept my focus on him
could have navigated me out of that
instead i bought into the narrative that
took me into a culture
which for me turned to be
very
promiscuous um um
it was
it was pretty damaging and i i i'm a
walking miracle because i should be dead
you know i should have been an aids
statistic instead
i'm not hiv positive i'm hiv negative
and
and god spared my life and i think that
he spared my life for a purpose as i
believe in his
his word and the destiny that he had in
mind for me and knowing that i would
respond to him
and
so i want to be clear that that i'm all
for the things that brings
quality
and goodness and health
to somebody's life um even if they don't
believe in god you know that that's
important too and i asked the question
today you know can satan make you happy
and
clearly
he can for a period of time but there
are eventually on this earth you know
you can't have a long happy life living
according as a you know believing the
way you want to believe you don't have
to believe in god's ways but as a
christian i do believe in creation and i
do believe in
and you know the beginning of time has
the end of time because of the stain of
sin that's on this earth and then
there'll be sin no more
on one day so i want to live my life
today so that i have an eternity with
jesus christ but it's only based not on
becoming a checklist christian by saying
i got to do this i got to do this i got
to do this but i need to court time and
be with jesus and let him
fulfill my life and bring wholeness to
my life in his means instead of in those
that i construct for myself that's right
that's right i think the world is
constantly trying to shove down our
throats
what we need to be and who we are and
you know a lot of people push back
against like well i don't want to
believe in some bible and somebody
telling me what to be but yet the
world's constantly trying to do that
same sort of thing as well yeah so as
much as people want to fight against
this idea of like you know the bible's
so controlling and it's just forcing you
to do this right um it's giving you
principles that actually is promising
you peace and and happiness and
long-lasting joy right
and and um you know you really do get
life if you find your life here like
you're like oh that's it i'm just gonna
live for the life now i've only got one
life to live so i'm gonna have my fun
now right
you get that reward now
but god's also promising that you know
what if you
actually die to self and you give me
your life i'll give you that life down
the road so it's like you still get this
reward it's just like do you want it now
or do you want it later is it for you or
is it for you know some greater purpose
of that and i think that um you know
people don't distinguish that but the
world is really offering you almost like
this the same but opposite of what god
is offering you and and but they're just
saying you need to take it right now
and uh you know in the name of freedom
they're they're offering you do whatever
you want but we know from a christian
perspective that the more freedom that
you have in this world the bible
actually calls that a slave we become a
slave to sin you know and so true
freedom is found in christ and you know
he's the one that sets us free from all
this bondage that we've gotten ourselves
into or the devil's deceived us with
absolutely so
it's interesting too that you know
there's while there are biblical laws
i've always found it interesting that we
we have laws of the day you know there's
reasons that you don't speed you know
you don't go you know 90 miles around a
curve that says you know 20 miles an
hour because you know you're going to
turn over you're going to flip over and
kill yourself
and you know there you know we have laws
you know that are protecting children
laws that are protecting lives you know
murder
you know it's not legal and those kinds
of things but they really stem from from
the word of god to begin with so even
non-believers of god even marriage
itself is a derivative of from scripture
otherwise it wouldn't exist that's right
that's right there's actually laws there
that you know mistreat your spouse and
and you know you you have an unhappy
home yeah show show and shower them with
love and and you know give them the
the things that their hearts really are
craving for and that's either love or
respect you know between a male and a
female and and there is a happiness that
can ensue there and so you know i i see
those principles at play as well
so as we hear more and more about um
conversion therapy i you know i'm
continuing to research i would i would
encourage a a listener
even identifying as lgbt to maybe look
because i know that when i lived in the
culture when you have like-minded people
that come together we don't always
research the stuff but if you begin to
do the research and and it does take
some digging around because i didn't
even pay
much attention to this i was so
defensive that in my books and and and
my conversations in my presentations i
was very clear with people i don't
condone conversion and reparative
therapy
and then i began to think about it um as
i started engaging with some other
ex-gay ministries
wait a minute what is it that i'm
protecting you know can you tell me what
conversion therapy is and i begin to
find out and figure out that that mental
health specialists don't put out a
shingle that says i'm a conversion
therapist
and
so then when i started looking up the
definition and found that it it included
so many different things that didn't
have anything to do with
aversive techniques at all it's just all
a part of the narrative
and as you encounter those today who are
mental health specialists um
they don't
you know you might find a christian
therapist who is going to advocate for
the principles of scripture
but you don't go there forcibly you go
there on your own accord
um
and probably 99.9 of the time they're
not shocking your brain trying to make
you right you know subscribe to their
ways
so i'm i'm investigating this because
you know as i see the criminalization
taking place more and more i think it's
also important for politicians to know
that their from a christian perspective
is like we're kind of caught like deer
in the headlights like what yeah we
don't what do you mean i can't pray with
somebody who wants to leave the lgbt
community
you're going to impinge upon my
religious freedom yeah isn't that crazy
i mean if you really do subscribe to a
biblical world view and we see that
there are people that are caught up in
all kinds of things not just not just
you know homosexuality or whatever like
this but this is something that is
alarming
and should alarm any of us christians
that a government can now all of a
sudden have power to
prevent something it begs the question
what's next yeah i mean i mean
are we seeing this in our country yeah
we are yeah we are big time well just a
couple of days ago
you know before taping this uh joe biden
has you know made an executive order to
put a ban on conversion therapy we have
yeah here's a as
a slide
and to be honest i'm not sure because
i'm still trying to figure out what it
is
i'm not sure that joe biden maybe or
some of the legislators really have all
the facts together about conversion
therapy
who's who's giving the information who's
making the legislation they no doubt
have advisors around them that are you
know maybe parts and bits of these these
cultures and are saying no there's this
terrible thing that's happening over
here and i'm sure joe biden doesn't
necessarily have time to sit there and
go to the real research and
and look into this is this really
something so he's listening to every
who's driving the conversation yeah and
they're writing these bills i mean this
is this is alarming these are these are
not things that have happened
months ago this happened this week yeah
last week yes absolutely you know
so in my so it's perked my interest you
know because i i was sitting down and i
was um i was browsing on youtube and i
was trying to just look into more ex-gay
testimonies and find out what their
experience had been and i ran into a
a conversation with a mental health
specialist
that it said the title of it was a
closer look at ex-gay ministries and i
thought well i used to didn't even like
the x-gay term
um
but yeah i don't identify as a gay
person today i'd identify as a new
creation in christ or a believer or
redeemed and so
i thought well this is kind of talking
about me so let me have a look at this
and i know that from my perspective you
know there's there's like um in another
program that i did with you guys we
talked about the four different
perspectives
on
lgbt uh within christianity today one of
those perspectives was renown the
renounced position of where i gave my
life to christ i gave up the identity
from the world and i accepted the one
that jesus offers me and i was like yeah
this makes sense um that's where i am
and then the guy moved on to another
position which was the rebuild position
and i was like whoa wait a minute
there's more i mean i can i can move
past just surrendering to christ but i
could potentially have more in my life
and he begins to talk about how he
um is a
christian mental health specialist and
helps people who were willingly coming
to him and are seeking
for
for help in their lives and so we we
have a clip that we we thought that was
was interesting to contemplate and and
as a listener you know i think it might
be well worth going and looking at the i
think it's like an hour and ten minute
interview but i found it very very
interesting but i found that this was
was really interesting about andrew
rodriguez who is a mental health um
specialist and it intrigued me so much
that i i flew from washington to
pennsylvania to sit down with him for an
entire entire day and i had quite an
interesting conversation with him and i
would say that his efforts are are
genuine and and really um sincere in
wanting to help somebody who's wanting
to walk with christ awesome let's check
it out yeah as time went on we realized
wait
the
pro-gay lobby is using conversion
therapy as like a a ruse term
to straw man what we do
and
it's like a a way to say that what we're
doing is
gosh a few things
we don't those of us in the rebuild calm
we don't actually refer to ourselves at
least not anymore not since
i don't know
15 or so years
as conversion therapists or providing
conversion therapy because
one it gives this connotation of a
categorical change this idea of
conversion changing from one thing to
another
it's also
um
they've
the media and the
uh anti-therapy lobby has done a very
effective job with their propaganda
of conflating
any sort of therapy or ministry for
same-sex attraction
with
old forms of
uh
professional secular therapy for
homosexuality
that used to use aversive techniques
like say electroshock therapy or ice
baths or
shaming techniques uh
which is overstated actually it's very
much overstated
but
you know prior to the 70s or
some point early in the 80s
because the
homosexuality was in the dsm as a mental
disorder
then whatever sort of therapy approach
or uh
psychological intervention was in vogue
at the time was being used
to treat homosexuality and the
behavioral therapists
would use
um
among other approaches
aversive techniques
so
they will conflate that approach because
it just seems like it's harmful it must
be harmful if they're using electroshock
and
and ice baths and
tricking some of needles whenever they
get aroused by same-sex uh stimulation
stimuli
so
they'll just use that and they'll
conflate it then well this stuff still
exists in the form of ex-gay ministries
you won't find an x-game ministry that
has
electroconvulsive therapy as one of
their interventions i think and most of
their even uh
i'll also make a distinction here within
the rebuild column there's also kind of
two streams because there will be those
who believe that change is possible
through through jesus
uh
through
um
deepening a relationship with christ and
through the intervention of the holy
spirit
and so they're just going to take a
ministry approach
then there are those who believe well
change is possible also through like
modern psychotherapy
and then there's me who thinks hey let's
use both
so i love seeing christian therapists uh
use the best of both
so i see a couple of things out of this
conversation that he's starting to have
that
that's kind of really interesting i mean
he's addressing that yeah there there
were some negative uses of this thing
over here but you can't all of a sudden
then say world and we should just not
ever have anything to do with that
whatsoever because um because of this
thing the negative about yeah it's
almost kind of like um you know if
you've ever heard uh wine is good for
your blood or something you know good
for your heart i mean that's what it is
good for your heart right well
i saw this article one time that talked
about um you know it's actually the
grapes and some some elements that are
inside of those grapes that's actually
what's good for you not the alcohol so
you can yeah so you can actually achieve
that same effect if you just have grape
juice right and and it's like everybody
wants to go like oh it's you know it's
all about the the wine right but you
know if you believe wine is is is
harmful to you or whatever right you
wouldn't say then well then we can't
have anything to do with grapes right
you don't throw out the baby with the
bats well it's like no don't ferment
them and you can have them fresh and you
know what i mean so um i think i see the
same sort of thing happening here is is
yes there needs to be rules and laws
against anything that's harmful and
damaging to people
but um you know i think that there's
also some very beneficial things by
using um you know some some things that
the bible suggests or prayer or you know
right so if we wrote into law
that we were criminalizing therapy that
would bring physical harm to someone
wouldn't that be a better approach to
this rather than taking somebody's power
of choice away from them right right and
the fact that um i've seen a little bit
of this interview that uh of the first
guy that we showed that that talked a
little bit about um you know them them
you know condemning anything like even
prayer like that's where i just like ooh
this is just this you can't go down
you're smearing
you know with a brush something that
that's not those are not all christians
you know i don't in fact i don't know
well outside of maybe westboro baptist
church you know
that would not be the approach on the
lgbt issue for me yeah but i think and
that's a good example as well like um
you know i think that there are some
uses of christianity that are
mean and harmful i mean standing and and
being aggressive and and being angry
with people and yelling slanderous
things at them you're going to you know
the hot place that burns forever and and
you know you're kind of like trying to
really win someone over by with this
like you know spirit of anger isn't the
best use of of probably a way to get to
their heart right
um but that doesn't mean that okay so
that's bad so let's just do away with
all religion and i think that's kind of
what i'm hearing here
is what's happening um and uh yeah this
is because i think jesus has through his
word some good recommendations for us to
consider as christians and again with
with the ability to be able to have
religious freedoms in america you know
as christians we we do have these rights
to be able to believe what the bible
says just as buddhists have rights and
and you know other other denominations
have rights but if we begin to um put
everybody into one
one bucket you know we don't we don't
we're gonna smother in there we don't we
don't fit all in there with the same
beliefs right right
well wayne i truly believe god has a uh
an ability to change our hearts he can
take us and create us into a new
creation in fact that's exactly what the
bible describes you know is it gives you
that list of things that will keep you
out of heaven and it says you know as
was such some of you
you were that but you are no longer that
anymore and uh i love that verse yes and
i really do believe that that uh it
doesn't matter it's not just
homosexuality you can swap that sin out
for any other thing out there that uh we
all struggle with a straight man
struggles just as much as anyone else
with sexual sin
um and uh really this is a hitting at
the heart of it uh can god actually
resolve some of these things in our
lives can he actually convert our hearts
and can he win us and set us off in a
new direction so remembering
that god is invitational and not
forceful and so to to again to any
viewer
this is an invitation of of god it's
it's not anything christians are not
forcing this down somebody else has said
i do believe that there are christians
who have misrepresented christ but we
need to meet people on a one-on-one
basis
to see you know do i can i see jesus in
this person or am i seeing actually more
of the enemy in this you know in this
person
but um yeah give
give this some consideration some
thought do some web search and even
youtube search on this topic
and i have lots of ex-gay ministry
friends
who are totally open to
to having you come
and seek christ together with them but
if you don't want to we totally respect
that that's your choice and that's where
you want to be and we love and we care
about you as individuals we may not
endorse every single behavior that you
participate in and you may not endorse
every
behavior that i participate in but we
should still be able to come together
and reason together that's right thank
you guys so much for checking us out we
are very curious i'm sure many of you
are already commenting below but uh you
know please be respectful in the
comments below tell us what you think of
this topic um if you've come across
something that you would like us to look
at you know share that information with
us and like wayne said do a little bit
of internet research yourself because i
think you'll be surprised i i understood
conversion therapy as this total
negative thing until it was brought to
my attention and and hey yeah is there
really a lot of people doing this today
and so i was surprised by a little bit
of this research to find that uh you
know i'm sure some of it exists uh
somewhere and i'm sure you know on both
sides of the fence uh so you know we
need to prayerfully handle some of these
topics but this is a topic that is
coming to your doorstep because of what
has happened even in this last week in
our legislation so um this is inching us
one step closer and those freedoms that
we now enjoy are getting smaller and
smaller so keep this ministry in prayer
and if you guys want to look up where
can people find how to get a hold of you
wayne so at know hislove.org that's like
get to know him knoww know hislove.org
and you can contact me through the
website if you're interested in seminars
and presentations and discussions on
this
i'm open to speaking to any denomination
so or any group of people that would
like to have the conversation awesome
well thank you guys so much for
supporting this ministry with your
prayers with your comments with your
sharing we literally wouldn't be here
without the generosity of you guys so
thank you patreon donors for always
giving us the ability to keep our lights
on and give us this wonderful space to
work in and thank you for everyone that
suggests
conversations for us to have people to
get into conversations with and also
share our ministry with many many other
people out there and we thank you for
that and we hope to see you next week on
led live
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world
and in 1999 a movie titled the matrix
hit the world stage these stories are
often told and seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
you